how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
Wonder today we have an exclusive Batman
scoop things are getting really exciting
when it comes to the Batman we've had
our first official look at the bat suit
and then thanks to some leaked photos we
have seen the bat suit in its entirety
and we just recently got our first look
at the Batmobile and right off the bat
it's already looking like it's not going
to be a Batman film like Ben Affleck's
Batman or like Christian Bale's Batman
but Matt Reeves this take on the Batman
is going to be a brand new take that we
haven't seen in a while but as far as
what it's truly going to be about in
what direction they're going to take the
movie after the original movie we really
don't have a clue but today thanks to
insider Mikey such and we do know a
little bit about what the studio is
thinking for the next films now I warn
you if you are trying to avoid any and
all spoilers about the Batman and future
Batman movies you should click away now
if you're new be sure to subscribe to
stay up to all things relating to the
Batman I'm also doing a giveaway that
I'll talk about at the end so this is
coming directly from Mikey Sutton and it
says Robert Pattinson zhh Dark Knight
has yet to appear on the silver screen
as filming is underway but discussions
about the future of Matt Reeves as
Batman trilogy are beginning to float
about the initial entry has been
shrouded in mystery but information has
leaked here and there now the same can
be said of its future according to
various personnel the in-game beam
planned of this trio of Dark Knight
films as none other than death in the
family the late eighties story arc in
which the Joker kills Robin final
spoiler warning right here for anybody
who does not want any spoilers about the
future of this franchise apparently that
is the fate awaiting Robin here as well
but which Robin not still up in the air
however the event changes Batman a loss
of innocence in a way as we're dealing
with a relatively younger Bruce Wayne at
least compared to Ben Affleck somewhat
middle age turn and the question is who
kills Robin we are looking at yet
another Joker one not played by Jared
Leto the Joker is wild again and Batman
will face another tragedy as his
character develops deepening and growing
more intense and according to Mikey
Sutton that is the fate currently
awaiting Robin as the studio talks about
the future of this franchise
and that's something that we really
haven't seen with the past two
iterations of Batman we kind of had a
Robin in the Dark Knight Rises with
Joseph gordon-levitt
but he never donned a costume he didn't
really enter the Batcave to work with
Batman and he wasn't even called Robin
until one time at the end of the movie
but now it appears that this Batman is
going to introduce a true version of
Robin but according to what Mikey Sutton
has said the studio has planned it is
not a great fate for him the late
eighties run of death in the family does
end with the Joker killing Robin this is
apparently the same fate that the new
Robin that we're going to finally have
is going to face and from what we've
heard about the Batman it's going to
have a whole slew of villains tons of
villains so the fact that Batman would
need help and have somebody like Robin
help him makes a lot of sense and not to
mention zoe kravitz has been cast as
Selina Kyle
Catwoman now whether or not she's going
to be a villain or an antihero in the
movie has yet to be discovered
but we have seen some photos of her on a
motorcycle riding with Batman so it
seems like she may be more of an ally in
this Batman run than a villain so if
this all ends up being true what we're
looking at here is Batman Robin and
Catwoman all working together and if the
studio takes it the way that Mikey
Sutton says they're thinking about
taking it we are looking at yet another
Joker unless they happen to decide to
throw in Joaquin Phoenix's Joker and
connect it to this movie no one really
knows DC's plans at this point in time
for their extended universe we have
another Suicide Squad coming out that's
a remake but also has some of the same
actors playing the same characters birds
of prey in them fantabulous emancipation
of one Harley Quinn connected to the
original Suicide Squad yet is also
connecting to the new Suicide Squad so
we're really unsure of what DC is up to
but they very well could connect Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker to this movie not to
mention we really aren't too sure about
what time the new Batman series takes
place in at the end of Joker spoiler
alert if you haven't seen it yet
Joker becomes the Joker and one of his
followers kills Bruce Wayne's parents
does the Batman take place 25 something
years into the future and the Joker is
now at power we'll have to wait and see
which direction DC takes this but in the
meantime we can plan on Robin making an
appearance for the movie trilogy and
ultimately a Joker in the end so let me
know what you think about Dee's
these current plans they could always
change but what do you think if they
went down this route let me know in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe when
notifications turned on to enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 I'm picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof